il y a des mauvais coups d'état et des
bons coups d'état qui de mieux qu
emmanuel macron pour nous l'expliquer au
burkina faso par exemple ce n'est pas
bien le 24 janvier dernier est des
militaires annoncent avoir chassé le
président roch marc christian kaboré au
pouvoir depuis 2000 15 le président
kaboré avait été élu démocratiquement
par son peuple à deux reprises ce coup
d'état s'inscrit dans une succession de
plusieurs coups d'état militaires qui
sont extrêmement préoccupants dans un
moment où la région doit avoir une
priorité qui est la lutte contre le
terrorisme islamiste au mali ce n'est
pas bien non plus le 19 août 2020 contre
1 par des militaires mutins le président
ibrahim boubacar kéïta annonce sa
démission celle de son gouvernement et
celle de l'assemblée nationale la lutte
contre les groupes terroristes et la
défense de la démocratie et de l'état de
droit sont indissociables en sortir
c'est provoquer l'instabilité et
affaiblir notre combat ce n'est pas
acceptable
le mali qui a connu un coup d'état dans
le coup d'état pourra reprendre les mots
d' emmanuel macron le 25 mai 2021 le
colonel assimi goïta vice président de
transition et fait arrêter et démettre
de leurs fonctions le président banda et
le premier ministre moctar ouane après
deux ans de tensions croissantes les
relations entre paris et bamako semble
aujourd'hui avoir atteint un point de
non retour
l'ambassadeur de france au mali joël
meyer est invité à quitter le territoire
national dans un délai de 72 heures
cette mesure fait suite aux propos
hostiles et outrageux tenus récemment
par le ministre des affaires étrangères
et à la récurrence de tels propos par
les autorités françaises à l'égard des
autorités maliennes en dépit des
protestations maintes fois élever les
relations franco malienne ont pris chez
un nouveau tournant lorsque paris a
annoncé réduire la présence de la force
barkan qui lutte contre les groupes
armés djihadistes au sahel
bamako a dénoncé un abandon en plein vol
de la part de son allié français pour y
remédier les autorités maliennes aurait
selon l'elysée engagé les services de
wagner une société privée de mercenaires
russes parrish y voient la main de
moscou et laisser la russie accroître
son influence dans cette zone considérée
comme une chasse gardée française
c'est inconcevable pour la france en
afrique comme en europe la russie par
ses actions et ses discours privilégier
une stratégie d'intimidation elle choisi
la confrontation masqué qui est un
facteur de déstabilisation
je vous le disais il ya des bons et des
mauvais coups d'état au tchad ça va la
france a adressé son soutien à la junte
militaire dirigée par le fils du
président tchadien décédé le 20 avril
2021 des suites de blessures subies au
front contre des rebelles dans nord du
pays idriss deby itno qui a gouverné
depuis trois décennies
la france ne laissera jamais personne ni
aujourd'hui ni demain remettre en cause
la stabilité et l'intégrité du tchad
j'appelle à promouvoir la stabilité
l'inclusion le dialogue la transition
démocratique pourquoi ce deux poids deux
mesures de la france et de ses alliés
européens vis-à-vis des juntes
militaires alors que 53 soldats français
ont payé de leur vie leur engagement
contre le terrorisme au sahel depuis
2013 des personnalités africaines
remettent en question les intentions de
la france sur le continent
la france qui dit qu'elle des fonds la
démocratie elle est allée dans notre
pays l installer des chefs d'état qui
ont fait des coûts la france préserve
l'uranium avec areva qui est au niger
pays voisin du mali des parts de marché
aussi avec les multinationales
françaises qui viennent gagner les
marchés de travaux publics et autres
grands projets ils veulent préserver
leurs parts de marché or diamant uranium
phosphore pétrole charbon gaz
l'afrique est incontestablement le
continent le plus riche en terme de
ressources naturelles
dans un rapport de 2019 rédigé par hervé
gaymard ancien ministre et haut
fonctionnaire français on apprend que
les investissements directs français en
afrique sont passés de 6 milliards
d'euros en 2000 à plus de 56 milliards
en 2016